so much we have to talk about here but
it's just an emotional time all right I
I need a moment
okay Avengers endgame here's everything
going on in the first trailer it was at
issue let's start with that title Doctor
Strange memorably used the phrase an
infinity war to explain why he gave the
time stone to Thanos telling Tony Stark
were in the endgame now but that wasn't
the first time we've heard it in an MCU
film in age of Ultron while describing
the threat of alien invasion Tony
explained that up there that's the end
game and did you see that us had his
armor hung up on a scarecrow back at the
farm this symbolizes the fact that he's
retired now following the successful
snap but it's also a direct reference to
the original 1991 Infinity Gauntlet
comic did anyone else think fan o is
running his hands along the flowers at
his farm was reminiscent of Maximus in
his wheat fields from gladiator no just
me and this quick scene Bruce Banner
gets emotional while checking out the
profiles of some Avengers team members
we lost in the snap first up our ant-man
and spider-man
coincidentally the same two guys Bruce
was asking about in the last movie
doesn't it man into spider-man but if
you blinked you might have missed
another profile that he was reviewing
two challahs sister and wakanda's chief
scientist sharee Infinity Ward didn't
reveal what happened to sharee after the
snap so this is our first indication
that she was zapped into ash oh I liked
her on two costumes cap appears to have
returned to his stealth suit that we
last saw him sport in the Winter Soldier
this could be a nod to a potential
time-travel angle but it also could just
mean that he's done being a criminal on
the run
either way the trailer opens on a shot
of Tony using his Iron Man helmet to
record a message for pepper this
strongly resembles some concept art for
Tony's Avengers 4 helmet that the
internet first noticed earlier this year
perhaps the biggest what in a shot that
looks like it might be set outside the
Hong Kong sanctum sanctorum Black Widow
meets up with her old pal Clint Barton
but based on his new armor it looks like
good ol Hawkeye has completed his
transition into the superhero
Ronen he's not actually the original
Ronin that was Maya Lopez aka EKKO who
first appeared in daredevil comics in
the 90s she first donned the suit to
conceal her identity and gender and
named herself Ronan after the Japanese
word for a samurai without a master like
Hawkeye Ronan doesn't really have powers
she's just an Olympic level athlete with
incredible reflexes and martial arts
skills in the comics Clint took on the
Ronan persona following his own death
and resurrection but based on that
haunted look in his eyes it's probably
safe to assume that his wife and kids
didn't survive the snap Palmer man but I
don't know
shoot Thanos with a bunch of arrows or
whatever you got planned good luck
speaking of plans the trailer doesn't
make it entirely clear how the Avengers
are gonna well get to avenging but we
can make some educated guesses based on
what's here keep in mind this is all our
speculation we open with Tony drifting
on the guardianship the benatar and deep
space we last left him on Titan but he
was with nebula then and he certainly
appears to be alone on that ship maybe
she took off on a different craft from
Titan maybe Captain Marvel showed up and
invited her on a space roadtrip we just
don't know
but we do know that Gwyneth Paltrow has
teased not only appearing in the film as
Pepper Potts but also donning her own
version of the Iron Man armor peppers
Ironman persona is known as rescue so is
it possible she's going to fly out into
space and save her man or maybe Captain
Marvel will do it she's already in space
but we do know that this shot of clean
shaven Steve Rogers wistfully looking at
his old photo of agent Carter doesn't
bode well for him surviving this movie
and now I'm getting emotional again huh
okay I'm better
let's talk time vortexes the mid-credits
scene in ant-man in the wasp introduced
this idea and don't get sucked into a
time vortex
Janet Van Dyne warns Scott Lang not to
get stuck in a time vortex while he's in
the quantum realm but of course he does
get trapped in the quantum realm once
Janet and her family disappear in the
snap with seemingly
no way out so how does Scott get out and
meet up with the Avengers in this
trailer post snap well maybe he's a
scroll one of those evil shape-shifting
aliens from Captain Marvel or maybe he
purposefully plunges into a time vortex
to escape the quantum realm and if this
is possible could it also be possible
for the Avengers to return to the
quantum realm and use it as a way to get
back to the time before the snap
officially stopping Thanos and saving
the day well we just don't know but that
would help explain what Black Widow and
cap are talking about doing here this is
gonna works to you I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't maybe the thing that's going to
work Steve is time travel Great Scott
this is heavy
well that's all we found floating around
in the end game trailer but maybe you
saw something that got by us or just
want to shout out your favorite moments
hit us up in the comments
[Applause]